Bye love you work.
My name is Charlie,
my questions days associated with you as
a scientist and how you've evolved over
time to deal with both sides itself and
the ethics and morals associated with
sites.
So,
um,
I'll start off with this quote.
So science can tell you how to clean a
tyrannosaurus rex humanities can tell
you why this might be a bad idea.
So my question today is whether or not
you prefer to deal with,
um,
the like morals and ethics associated
with scientific concepts or the
exploration and explanation of the
concepts themselves and which one
engages you to a greater extent.
Charlie,
this is a great question,
but in mathematics you may have run
across the word integer and you know,
may know the word integral and you may
know the word integral.
It's integral to my outlook or whatever.
What we want is for everybody to be a
complete person with a complete point of
view,
a complete understanding of the process
of science,
which enables humankind to know nature,
but also to have an appreciation for
what it means to be a member of the
tribe,
to be a human,
to be living here on earth with other
humans and other species.
So we want you to have both an
appreciation for the process of science
and an appreciation for ethics or what
seems to be the best way to live,
the best way to conduct yourself on
earth and especially in the human tribe.
So with that said,
when it comes to ethics,
I always pretty much always harken to
evolution.
And here's the extraordinary claim,
and you can evaluate this charlie,
that not only is our size and shape the
number of fingers,
we have our eye color,
hair color,
skin color associated with our ancestors
and the genes that were passed to us
through the process of evolution.
But furthermore,
what we feel is a result of evolution.
Our ancestors who were antisocial jerks
got pushed aside by the ones that were
perhaps more social and less jerky.
However,
you don't want to be meek.
You want to have the right level of
aggression in the right level of
accommodation with your fellow
creatures.
And uh,
when it comes to ethics,
when you look at whatever scheme you
feel is most reasonable to pass your
genes on into the future,
that usually leads to what we all
consider ethical behavior.
And the classic example,
and this is not my fault,
don't come running to me Charlie.
Okay,
this,
this is a thought experiment,
Charlie.
Okay,
don't bust my chops.
It's not a real thing.
The house is on fire.
You have a chance to either save your
son or your grandson by the rules of
this thought experiment.
You can't save both.
There's no,
you can't say,
well I find a fire hose and I call in
uh,
the terminator and he can walk through
Friday.
No you're not.
No,
you pick your grandson,
you will always pick the grandson.
You will feel that because that passes
the genes farther into the future.
If you're a guy,
if you're a woman,
uh,
the,
you'll pick whichever offspring is
farthest in the future.
It's the same thing.
So,
uh,
when it comes to how you should treat
other people who are not part of your
family,
everybody who's a human is in somehow is
somehow related.
If you go far enough back,
everybody is related.
Troubling is that may seem.
And so you,
this old thing expressed as the golden
rule rule,
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you.
If you can do that,
Charlie,
I think you will get through life as
well or better than anyone.
Carry on.